[Music]
most see a family Pat a funny looking
fowl or just plain old livestock but a
special few see a champion
meet the furry
feathered and the outright fabulous not
to sound superficial but she's got a
great body locked in Inseparable bonds
alpacas are Like Oxygen every Katie's
different they each have a soul and a
personality with their loyal humans we
do this because we love this they're my
children sometimes they talk to me
they're traveling America wait a lot
taking on the very best he just has it
all and together thank you we did it
they'll stop at nothing when you put
your bird out there you want to win you
got this no matter what I love you if
you're really a true competitor then
you're going for gold
people usually react by going
you show what
[Music]
tucked away
in this quiet Suburban neighborhood
hello babies are we ready for dinner
Carol and Stuart jacquez have finally
found the ideal home to raise their
family come on girls well we walked into
this particular house it was 4 000
square feet which is nuts because it's
just Stuart and I but it was
perfect for the cats
[Music]
they are my kids
within six months of moving in so I
shouldn't have favorites but she's one
of my favorites she is his favorite
Carolyn Stewart had transformed their
two-story contemporary Colonial
into the ultimate cap pad
they have nine tier cat trees eight feet
high
that's our grooming station kittens are
little piggies they step in their poop
we have a birthing room
this little baby is two weeks old
they also have their catio which is an
enclosed area that they can climb but
it's totally protected I love my babies
but Carol's much more than your typical
cat lover she's a force to be reckoned
with
and the ultra competitive world of cat
shows
Carol is considered an expert in raising
Ragdoll cats
who become national champions look at
that beautiful blue eyes
ragdolls are famous for their large oval
baby blue eyes
and light silky coats
but not all ragdolls are created equal
but it's bath time
this season Carol's rolling out a new
contender
year old rookie who has the cat World
purring this is Rockstar Rebel
Rockstar Rebel is already the number 11
rag doll in the world
and Carol's determined to make him
number one
and that is extremely difficult to do
[Music]
but Rockstar Rebel must first travel to
Monterey California
where he'll battle 125 of the most elite
felines
at the prestigious cat fancier show
[Music]
you one kisses too
yeah you are done
I'm crossing my fingers that Rockstar
Rebel will do very very well and I will
groom him to the nth degree to make sure
that he looks the best possible ever
okay mister you're all ready to go let's
get in the dryer okay
foreign
takes kind of the mulch moisture out and
then what I use this fryer for is to
kind of do the final fluff
oh
you have to remember to keep your mouth
closed it's always in my mouth cat hair
is a condiment around here
I always get it in my mouth
are you ready to go buddy
well the entire cat world is heading to
Monterey
about 3 000 miles to the east Gotta Love
February
it's okay kids it's just me another
breed of animal lover prepares his furry
contenders for one of the biggest events
of their season
I love rabbits get you covered up so you
don't get snow on you
I talk to my animals all the time
even though the rabbits when I'm
speaking to them they may not understand
the words I'm saying but they hear the
tone they know it's me
and tomorrow Eric Stewart and his
beloved rabbits will be here attempting
to dominate the annual passarba rabbit
show the sarba is the Pennsylvania state
Rabbit Breeders Association and everyone
waits to go to pasarba every year oh my
God that is our Crown Jewel event
with the big event kicking off in only
24 hours this peaceful wintry morning is
truly Eric's Calm before the storm it's
okay girl
it's so great to just sit there quietly
and you can hear them crunch crunch
crunch crunch
everyone's eating everyone's happy
Eric's unbridled love for rabbits began
at a young age
I raced Holland Lops in English spots
I would always be attuned to what are
the behaviors how are the rabbits
looking how do they view the world you
could say I'm a rabbit nerd but I'm
probably the rabbit nerd
Eric's infatuation has elevated him to
the highest ranks of rabbit royalty
one of the industry's most respected
judges
and has raised multiple national
champions
in recent years Eric's specialty has
become French angoras a breed known for
their long thick coats
they're wonderful producers of one of
the finest fibers on the planet
angora's wool is gently removed without
any harm to the rabbit
this is all Angora so this this comes
from the rabbit and I'm spinning it
since I don't have any hair on my head
most of the hats the garments that I
wear are made from fiber from my animals
but Eric won't Shear his rabbit's wool
for 18 months to achieve the densest
coat possible it's something Discerning
judges look for on the way to Best in
Show the win best and show at cassarba
is a huge deal I've been raising rabbits
over 30 years and I've only won it three
times I think I'm the one who is one at
the most
even though we talk about like I won
Best in Show
[Music]
really it's about the rabbit I'm proud
of them I guess that's how a parent
feels when they're kid you know when's
the big game
and Eric fully believes his two-year-old
doe pretty girl is poised to steal the
show at this year's pasarba
[Music]
she's not a good french Angora she's a
fantastic French Andorra and not to
sound superficial but she's got a great
body
it takes about six months to prepare a
French Angora for show
the thing she has working against her is
her Affinity to me we've bonded a lot
over the past year and I can't be around
when she's on the judging table because
she hears my voice and she wants to jump
up in my arms
and you can see why I say that I'm
sometimes a little concerned strangely
enough Eric's Inseparable bond with his
rabbit hopefully she doesn't try to do
this to the judges
could cost them that coveted
best-in-show trophy you spend so much
personal time and we develop strong
relationships when it's time for her to
go on the show table that's when she
needs to pose that is not play time
there's no points for Q
wish us luck
you're here
[Music]
with the Monterey cat show only a day
away Carol has offered to Mentor her
friend an occasional rival Dodie Johnson
Jody is a very special friend of mine
she's a fairly new breeder and she's
very positive I like to be around
positive people so Jody is coming with
me to Monterey
I just love Dodie professionally I do
hair and permanent makeup not so
professionally I do cats Persians and
exotic short hairs and Persians are the
really long coat they have the smashed
faces big round eyes
come on Sequoia
[Music]
Koya is Dodie's top contender in the
Persian kitten category oh it's okay
[Music]
when you have a ball of energy that
loves being on the table like Sequoia
does she just shines she is the J-Lo of
cats
Sequoia will compete in Monterey
alongside Dodie's more mature Rising
Star Alice
Persians and the Exotics their standards
are written for the males Alice she's
got the body of a boy so when you have a
female that can keep up with the males
that's what you want we love Miss Alice
she's my girl
foreign
let's get this train moving don't let me
forget the other cats Carol and Dodie
load up for the four hour drive down the
coast to Monterey
while the intensity of competition is
nothing new for a veteran like Carol
relative newcomer Dodie is eager to
notch another win I'm very excited about
the show in Monterey Carol's working on
a vest I'm working on a vest if you ask
Carol she's gonna say she's gonna get
the best but we know it'll be me we'll
see it makes for fun competition but
we're supporting and rooting for each
other we are getting there babe no
problem plenty of space we can take 10
more cats at least
but I'll get it first that is the plan
they're already talking to us they're
going to talk to us the whole way and if
Carol gets it first I'm just gonna kick
her out of her car
[Music]
I know it was a long trip
when we get the grooming stuff up and
we'll be ready well you see this huge
facility and
it may be empty now
we hear Echoes it's really empty
but it won't be long before you'll
barely be able to hear yourself think or
move because this is going to be filled
with rabbits
in fact anybody who's anybody will be
here to compete at the sarba
I actually have no idea where I'm going
you guys don't have any idea where the
mini Rex go
berlina Reynolds has traveled
cross-country from her home in
California which she shares with about
30 mini Rex rabbits okay my rabbits are
like therapeutic for me they bring me
joy
oh gosh I thought I sat on her rabbit
what got me into rabbits was when I was
a child I got into 4-H and learned about
rabbit showing and they were Rex rabbits
decades later berlina returned to the
breed she loved as a child and began
showing them in competitions in 2006 I
discovered that there was this new
variety that I hadn't known previously
it's a blue-eyed white then I soon
learned that they were not very
competitive you're sort of looked down
upon for even showing them so I took
that as a challenge
berlina was relentless in championing
her underrepresented breed and her
efforts paid off I have been winning
Boston show with my blue eye whites was
always very shocking to me because I
just know where I came from and where
they are now
she's a beautiful rabbit
it's all led to this weekend and one of
the biggest stages berlina's rabbits
have ever stepped foot on no loving guys
and she believes top Contender Jade is
ready for the spotlight Jade is one of
my favorites for sure I actually have
pictures I took when she was really
young I just expected great things for
this rabbit
[Music]
Eric Stewart right now is the top French
Angora breeder he's like done the
ultimate to invest in show at the
national show so he's where I want to be
someday you're borlenska you can do
anything yeah right
all right yeah I'll see you good seeing
you I'm nervous there are very good
rabbits here hopefully I do well
[Music]
foreign
cake brownie sundae welcome to Monterey
California's East of Eden cat fancier
show
it's my Norwegian Forest cat we know
you're number one at home huh
come here
Carol and Dodie are getting their cats
settled inside their tents for the
two-day show and look at this body wow
like most cat competitions there are no
cash prizes I need a bigger table okay
so there we go
but to every competitor under this roof
Championship ribbon is priceless when
you get these wins it makes you feel
proud he is amazing oh my goodness and
the love of our animals and the bragging
rights winning can be a powerful high
but the rules for judging Cat shows are
far more sobering
the cat fanciers Association show rules
and breed standards total 184 pages
but don't panic we've got the cliff
notes
that show judging takes place in
multiple Rings simultaneously
Pedigree Cats are separated by short
hair and long hair categories
as well as breed color and adult or
kitten class a judge Awards points based
on a written standard that includes
overall balance as well as head body
coat and bone structure
in each ring cats are awarded placements
for color
breed and Division
then the judge selects their top 10 cats
who are brought back into the ring for
finals
based on the combination of finals and
points received a cat can earn its
Champion titles Grand Champion double
Grand Champion Triple quadruple and the
absolute ultimate title Supreme grand
champion
and supreme is Carol's goal for Rockstar
Rebel here in Monterey
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on hold on
be proud of him and we think he's
gorgeous
how are you I'm good Carolyn Dodie join
up with friend and fellow competitor
Rosemary Cruz like Carol she's come to
Monterey in a quest for Supreme
her grand champion is goby the toyger
so watch Me While I Work
right now he's a baby he's only 11
months so if he's this good looking out
what's he gonna look like as a fully
matured cat
twiggers are one of the newest breed of
cats
intended to resemble
a toy tiger
Kobe was literally born to be shook out
well a cat isn't just a pet it's
literally a family member you're gonna
jump we're gonna jump he's dead Alex is
my husband and he's definitely 100 a cat
daddy
and my girls are absolutely animal
lovers
[Music]
hey go with Daddy
here take this with you
but now that it's show time here in
Monterey
Rosemary is all business
laser focused on Gobi winning Supreme
grand champion
people say oh I come to Cat shows
because I love it yeah we all love it
but I'm not dropping all this money to
just come hang out and see friends when
you're spending two three thousand
dollars every weekend we're competing
for titles we're competing for
recognition I'm here for the competition
I'm here to win
the stage is set for a dramatic weekend
[Music]
fired up baby girl
I would love love Hoya to make every
final today Dodie has high hopes for
both her cats my goal for Alice is to
get that one best so we can get a
supreme
but now
there's a problem
[Music]
it seems nature isn't cooperating with
Dodie's agenda with the show about to
begin Alice starts to behave strangely
Alice is in heat
you just don't know because when they're
in heat you don't know what's going to
happen
[Music]
for serious rabbit lovers Lebanon
Pennsylvania is a bucket list
destination
I love him he's my baby
a camera shy too
aging Brandon please report to the youth
contest area look at us we're being
modeled thousands of rabbits
representing all 50 recognized breeds
are ready to hop into the ring and the
last rabbit standing will be named Best
in Show
[Music]
I know see she always has to try and
crawl up on my chest huh baby a pretty
girl all judges please report to your
tables to begin this is it you're on
your own now Eric Stewart is wearing two
hats this weekend
as a competitor pursuing an
unprecedented fourth Best in Show at
pasarba with his French Angora pretty
girl
this is the tan group
as well as judge presiding over several
other rabbit breeds
all of them have some kind of color in
their ears around their eyes their
nostrils and their belly what I'm
judging it's like you switch gears I
have judged the neighborhood of about a
hundred thousand rabbits in my lifetime
so far regardless of what breed you're
looking at it all comes down to breeding
to a standard
that standard has been established by
the American rabbit readers Association
50 standards to be exact
it's got a good head it's a little bit
narrower at his shoulders but it's good
texture and good finish just needs a bit
more density
so the rabbits aren't really competing
against each other they're all chasing
an ideal vision of perfection
hey guys so pretty
berlina Reynolds has zeroed down her
blue-eyed white named Jade is as close
to Perfection as her past best in show
winners
it's okay Jade
you're dirty she decided to pull some
fur out either that means she's pregnant
or she's just hormonal
[Music]
pregnant rabbits often use their own fur
to line their nests they can also become
moody or even aggressive oh
me
luckily it was a surface nip but the
breeds chisel shaped teeth are capable
of doing serious damage to human skin
and Berlin's chances of winning the
rabbit bites the judge they can be
disqualified
Mickey Rex Open Table 29. the blue-eyed
whites are up next for judging berlina
needs to quickly calm Jade or the judge
who handles her will be playing a
dangerous game of rabbit roulette we're
gonna start the blue-eyed whites have
Jade
as Eric judges her pet berlina can
barely watch
it's hard for me to watch my RV judge
honestly inside I'm nervous and worried
Jade has been winning a lot for me
lately but I don't want a rabbit that's
biting people and especially the judge
little does Eric realize he's handling a
hormonal rabbit with a hair trigger
[Music]
judging is underway on the first of two
days at the cat fancier show in Monterey
California
[Music]
she's got that great kitten playful
thing because Maine Coons or kittens for
probably nearly two years I think he ate
his favorite toy Rosemary Reddy's Gobi
to enter his first ring of the weekend
we're gonna have a great show our number
one goal is to Supreme Gobi today it's
gonna be a long day
but to make it to Supreme Gobi has to
clear a few hurdles starting with a
first place win in color breed or
division in this judging round
we're really excited to see what he does
I'm hoping today's the day today's the
day
I've never seen that abandonment before
spider
beautiful braided pattern on him nice
profile when gobi's being judged anxious
is one of the things I feel so as far as
knowing what judge would do for you you
just really never know gotta check your
belly
renowned show judge Susanna Shawn knows
exactly what her fellow cat critics are
looking for here
we're not judging based on how cute they
are or how friendly they are every breed
has a written standard and we judge the
cats very quickly when we pull out
various teasers and the cat is following
it we're able to see eye shape correctly
if we make them look a certain way we
can see the profile without actually
having to feel it constantly beautiful
glitter
yes young man the judge clearly likes
what she sees very nice
Gobi needs only one first place best of
to move on
this color got some division at best
debris and he's awarded three
Gobi did great in that ring hopefully
get our Supreme today
the Rosemary's plan for Gobi doesn't
stop there
today Supreme tomorrow the world
our next go on the list is make it top
25 in international which gives you the
bragging right to say you have one of
the top 25 kids in the world
[Music]
in the main hall at caserba
berlina watches anxiously as Eric Gets
Ready to judge Jade who's possibly
pregnant
and definitely irritable
[Music]
hey Jade
the rabbits will pick up my energy if
I'm feeling tense or nervous and they
might in turn become nervous and
agitated or so I have to make sure I am
calm and relaxed she too has a very neat
round head that balances with the size
of her body
she has also very good ears
so
today
first place is Jade
[Applause]
and I can honestly say I've never raised
a blue eyed white as good as that one
she's just been gorgeous she's been
winning for me and now she's a champion
and yeah she's one of my favorites right
now and she's sweet too
as berlina gathers her rabbits
she realizes something's amiss
is this mine no it's not
it could be hard to tell there's a whole
bunch of rabbits especially on the show
table and you're like which one is mine
someone grabbed my shaded
because the rabbits are judged in groups
that match and breed age and color
taking the wrong rabbit is not so
uncommon
I think someone grabbed my rabbit but
berlina must soon leave for home
someone took it her only hope is that
event staff can help find her missing
rabbit in time
erlina hopes to get on the road soon but
she'd never leave without her missing
mini wrecks
oh you found her oh thank you wait are
you sure that's it
no no it's not mine somebody took the
wrong my shaded someone took it
fortunately yeah lost rabbits are
usually found because all show rabbits
are required to have an ID tattooed
inside their left ear
[Music]
all's well that ends well thank you for
berlina and her mini Rex rabbits
yay I'm very happy how it all turned out
and I'm very proud of my rabbits so it
was a good day
[Music]
so I'm here cat 112 to bring three
please put your calves up for the third
one day one of the cat fancier show is
leaping into its final rings of judging
remember
Dodie is preparing her older Cat Alice
for the ring
ready or not
Alice is in Raging heat which means she
needs to visit a boy
her showing her feet does not go against
her judging it's just she doesn't
present as well when they're stretched
out with their butt in the air
let's go Alice
[Music]
this is called the who dance
I call this the who who dance this mean
this cat is in Raging heat she is
preparing herself for a boy it's the
funniest thing I've ever seen in my life
yeah yeah I cannot help you in that way
at all Alice is like a ticking time bomb
and I have no idea what she's going to
do oh my gosh no way can I help
oh you are one funny girl
he is out of control out of control but
Nature Calls you do the best you can
look despite her frisky Behavior Alice
manages to win three bests
yeah yeah
on the other side of the hall Carol star
Ragdoll Rockstar Rebel is clawing his
way to the top of the awards ladder
Rockstar is only 30 points away from
being a quadruple grand champion
Still Point by color
if he Wows this judge
Carol's even bigger goal of achieving
Supreme Grand Champion is within their
grasp
it's a nine month old nail
I have a lot of confidence in Rockstar
however this particular judge is not
telling me a thing to see what direction
she's gonna go with him I just have to
wait and see how it's going to turn out
Rockstar not only wins First In Color he
also takes first in division far
surpassing the 30 points he needed
Rockstar is now a quadruple Grand
Champion so tomorrow we'll be going
forward to make him Supreme and it's
like whoa
okay Alice come on
Alice's unexpected friskiness compels
Dodie to hold off on pursuing Supreme
giving Alice a well-deserved breather
for the rest of the weekend this is a
part of nature it's not going to hurt
them but you really have to listen to
your cat they are part of your family
Dodie's kitten Sequoia however has won
all her finals so far and is now in the
cat fight for best long-haired kitten in
the show
okay and Carol is here for support
joining Dodie in the front row I'm
sitting on your lap yeah I'll give you a
little room that's fine you can sit on
my left anytime
very very nice kitten
[Laughter]
it says Persians can't fly
I love that she's just so comfortable
doing it very nice round head beautiful
flat face nice chin alignment short body
short tail short legs you want their
bodies to be big chunk of monkey short
and thick
everything is short on this cup
except for the coat the coat is like all
over the place right
this is my best in the ragdolls my
second
this is where you clap this is where you
clap not cry Sequoia just got a best I
am so excited that means out of all
these kittens in that ring she saw her
as the best thank you
such a good girl I'm so proud of you
congratulations
at the end of day one
Carolyn Doty do what they always do when
they reach the Winner's Circle whoever
does the best the other one buys them a
bottle of wine
I did let's see no I think I got I have
a second okay I'm not competitive at all
not me
I beat you at my behind I beat your
behind but we made every final but we
made every final yes good job tomorrow
Dodie the competitor will become a
cheerleader
supporting both Carol and rosemary as
they go for Supreme
it's a new day in Monterey
and the eyes of the country's top feline
Champions are locked on the prize
[Music]
all right gobs we gotta go Bud we gotta
go to the ring you ready you gotta get
ready Rosemary's toyger goby won enough
rings on day one to put the title of
supreme within Paws reach let's see am I
gonna make it pretty the goal for the
weekend in Monterey is for Gobi to
Supreme and get that title and if he
does that then we'll be on our way for
the international
goby knows it's showtime when Rosemary
delivers her final pregame pep talk best
behavior okay lots of cuddles lots of
love
they mail for that stuff you know that
Gobi now faces off against the weekend's
top ranking short hair cats
so get your Supreme
this ring is definitely the one we've
been working really hard for for him to
accomplish Supreme I
think that gut feeling's going to be
today
lovely toryger really strong orange
color has the look we're going for the
way the judge expressed herself about
they'll be in that ring was just really
nice nice muzzle and he's literally just
purring away at her
but will the judge's fondness for Gobi
be enough for him to receive the coveted
title of supreme
[Music]
tikka's newest Supreme
I'm very proud of Rosemary she knows
what she wants and she's going after it
finally got it guys
our best we have Supreme yay we're so
happy he's like I don't know what's
going on I just know I'm pretty and uh I
got a new Ward
[Music]
fine folks we would like you to know
that they will be pulling the tickets
for the cassava raffle at one o'clock
today is also the final day at the
passaba rabbit show one o'clock raffle
tickets will be moved where judge Eric
Stewart will take his turn as a
competitor
with three possiba best in shows already
under his belt Eric's pretty girl will
be hard to beat
[Music]
we're almost
as good as what we're gonna get
pretty girl spent the morning winning
all her rounds including best of the
French Angora breed
so there's only one more hurdle to hop
in hopes of taking home the goal
my goal is for a pretty girl to win best
and show
but with the judging round only minutes
away
you won't stay off of my neck
pretty girl is more focused on hugging
Aaron than kissing up to the judges
we spent a lot of time together girl
only the best of breeds can compete for
Best in Show but until they've selected
Best in Show it's just all anticipation
I want a Comber again
one more time
his grand entrance
I'm so excited she's handled this
exceptionally well she's about 18 months
old so to wait this long it's something
a lot of people would say well she's
Pastor Prime well we're gonna find out
whether or not she's past her prime
I'm actually nervous
I do love her
pretty girl
and it's just like even the look on her
face and the markings
I know that doesn't matter but it's not
enough
it's so inquisitive and allergic and
engaged well see that's why I can't be
anywhere near her like you see who's she
looking at right now
I'm her favorite person that's the
problem
in the best of show round like other
rounds rabbits aren't competing against
each other the winner is the rabbit who
comes closest to their own breed
standard of perfection it's nervous just
nervous once this is done then I won't
be as nervous
and finally it's pretty girls time in
the Limelight
when I'm not judging it's always the
same feeling I'm nervous I question
everything I want to comb her hair again
I know what her good attributes are but
that doesn't matter I'm the competitor
today it's about the judge and what they
think
everything comes down to this moment
all right let's give you all a round of
applause today
it really came down between two animals
you were French Angora and your mini
love
the rabbits head up here today all of
them are very nice representations of
their breed
I absolutely love pretty girl
but at the same time I'm also thinking
like I would be so excited for faith now
she's never won this but I can't help it
I want to win it too
in my opinion
this is probably the best
[Music]
and today that will be the mini log
congratulations
because outside
so well deserved babe so well in my
younger days I just wanted to win first
place but at this stage in my life it's
not always about the win the greatest
win is what I'm gaining from the
experience
oh thank you I'm so proud of you faith
it doesn't get any better than this
I love you I love you
that's what this is about but I'm not
going anywhere I'm a Young Man
It's the final day of the cat fancier
show in Monterey
10 cats from the best of breed rounds
have been summoned
and they're ready to compete as if the
last of their Nine Lives depends on it
you have to get first place in the final
in order to Supreme and that's what
Carol and Rockstar Rebel came here to do
Rockstar Rebel is the very confident
Kitty he's so comfortable in the show
ring and he's the love of my life
the unconditional love Carol feels for
every one of her cats is nothing new in
fact it's a lifelong trend
I was about six seven years old and we
were going to this farm
and there were kittens in the barn well
there was a particular kitten a little
orange tabby that just grabbed my heart
when my parents came out to leave I was
saying please can I have this Kitty and
they said no we can't take that kitty
home
we got into the car and my dad started
driving and I was looking back at the
barn watching thinking there goes my
kitty and he stopped and he backed up
all the way to the bar and he said go
get your kitty
it was the best day of my life
40 years after that day on the farm
Carol left a lucrative career in the
tech industry to show her prized pets
full time
found her life's calling
discussion
[Music]
no running
now Carolyn Rockstar have climbed to the
cat show summit we're hoping we've got
the nerves going so we'll see
young Ragdoll boy
Carol can hardly watch
the heavy hips the booty in the truck
it's a broadness in the shoulders inside
I am full of emotion but on the outside
I'm stone-faced to not sway the judge
the Symmetry to the bicolor pattern the
ear is framing the corner
[Music]
best rag doll
[Applause]
I want a picture oh my God
rock star Rebel just Supreme Rockstar
did Fabulous we couldn't be happier how
this show turned out
the cat show season is still young but I
think Rockstar has the potential to make
number one Ragdoll in the world I used
to breathe our Nick show is in Corpus
Christi Texas and I can't wait
thank you thank you
I heard that scream and I went she got
it I did oh I have to call Stuart
hi honey guess what
rock star Rebel just supremeed
[Music]
yeah our little boys growing up
I'll call you when I'm on my way home I
love you
okay thanks honey bye
[Music]